[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar data integrity and connectivity
for lab balances
i'm kayleigh bach of labyrinths and i
will be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by sartorius
to learn more visit sartorius.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to know welcome our speaker
sebastian zeber
global product manager software
solutions at sartorius
and joining us for our live q a session
today is peter hickey
manager of application specialists for
lab weighing at sartorius
sebastian you may now begin your
presentation
hello everyone welcome to our
presentation about data integrity and
connectivity for lab instrument
let me briefly introduce you myself my
name is sebastian lieber i am product
manager at the tutorials lab instruments
in germany
and i am delighted to be here today to
talk about 30 minutes
how to data integrity problems can be
prevented in the lab and what are the
connectivity requirements for a modern
lab
instrument the presentation today is
interesting for different stakeholders
when it comes to the purchasing of a new
laboratory instrument there are
different interests
i think the most important is that the
instrument produce trusted results
but we have also the laboratory staff
who need an instrument that is easy to
use
support them in their daily work and
increase the overall efficiency in the
laboratory
on the other side is qa
which must ensure that all compliance
requirements are met especially here it
is important that an instrument support
compliance without slowing down the user
in their daily work
and
yeah another important player today is
the it department
for them the focus is on ensuring that
the tool can be easily integrated into
existing and future i.t environments
meets all the i.t security standard and
does not require a high level of support
or
operational maintenance
as you can see the requirements for a
modern laboratory instruments are high
especially when it comes to an essential
laboratory instrument such as a balance
which is used in many different
areas like production or qa
i would like to start with a brief
introduction to the topic of data
integrity
and after that i show examples from fda
warning letters of different data
integrity violations and how these can
be prevented by using a modern
laboratory instrument
so why is data integrity so important
all of our decisions like a batch
release are based on information and
results from our daily laboratory work
and
if we have incorrect data or incorrect
information
these lead us to wrong decisions
and if we make wrong decision that
increases the risk of compromising our
product safety and quality
and we know if the product has not the
safety and quality what it should have
it can have negative impact on the
product cost and more important on our
patients health and the patient safety
and at the end this breaks the trust
between our patients inspectors and
stakeholders
and also
we lose our brand reputation and
therefore
it is so important that we make the
right decision based on the right data
so what is data integrity
with data integrity we want to cover two
major goals the first one is we want to
ensure that the data is recorded exactly
as intended or observed
on the other hand we want also to ensure
that the data remains the same as when
it was originally recorded and this over
the entire data life cycle
and we know
a data life cycle in a gxp
environment can be 20 to 30
years based on the different regulations
and
yeah
these
principles of data integrity
doesn't come up with computerized
systems we have to follow the same
principles also when we work
handwritten or create handwritten
records
but what we will see in the next slide
is that when we work electronically
and with computerized system we can
increase the efficiency and the
reliability of our data
yeah
how important the topic of data
integrity is we can also see from the
listed violations in
fda warning letters where data integrity
issues featured in more than 65 of all
ledgers in 2019
this shows us on one hand that the topic
data integrity is strongly in the audit
focus
of
different authorities
and on the other hand also how different
the violations are so this can be for
example that an sop was not follow or
simply no sop exist
the data was not transferred completely
or correctly
and here also remember this can be
related to digital records but also to
manual data transfer for example to lab
notebook
or
another very
common topic is everything around the
audit trail for example the instrument
did not have an audit trail the auditory
was deactivated
or simply the auditory entries were not
reviewed
i will show examples of this later and
also how digitalization
and a modern laboratory instrument
effectively prevent these issues
you should also always keep in mind that
the data integrity is not only relevant
for electronic data
paper-based records are also
subject to the same requirements
but
often a good and well-planned digital
approach is safer and more efficient in
the everyday laboratory life
so
how can we prevent this
first of all
organizations should follow good
documentation practice to assure
the completeness consistency and
reliability of the records and therefore
follow the aqua principles
what are these aqua principles
yeah first of all
the a is for attributable
that means the record contains all
metadata
like username instrument and timestamp
and not only a ph or weighing value
without any
information
around then
our record or our data must be
legible or also known as traceable
that means the data is readable
understandable and can be fully
reconstructed by people who are
reviewing the record
our data must also
be recorded at the time as it was
generated or observed
and especially here we can see how
digitalization and connected system help
as typically in these kind of systems
the value is stored immediately
electronically by the system and
does not require a manual
data transfer
the data must also be original
original data means in this context
the first
capture of the result or the information
and this data must be signed reviewed
and readable over the entire
retention period which can be in a gxp
environment 20 to 30 years
therefore you should use standardized
data formats instead of vendor-specific
whenever it's possible where the data
can also be read in future maybe after a
change of an operating system
last but not least
our data must be accurate
that means that the data is correct
complete and reliable
this includes on one hand that the
system like the balance or the limbs
that is generating the data is qualified
and the validated state
and the data itself are regularly
reviewed
but also that if for example errors are
found in the record the error and the
correction of the error
is documented cleanly with the reason
the timestamp of the correction
and
the signature of the person who have
correct the record
so when you buy a new laboratory
instrument you should make sure that the
instrument has all the technical
features to support you in implementing
the data integrity requirements
what are these features first of all
the instrument should have a
comprehensive audit trail
it should provide you a user management
with personalized user accounts
an electronic signature function
very useful is also a time
synchronization feature
it should have a backup functionality
and it should you provide different
interfaces and protocols for the safe
data transfer of the results into
another software system like lims or eln
in the next slide i will show you how
you can use these different features
to prevent data integrity issues
and i will do this with examples from
our cubist 2 balance
the cubist 2 balance from sartorius
provides all these features without the
need of any additional pc based software
this makes it very easily for you to
integrate the balance directly into your
lims or eln system
and it reduce also the validation and
maintenance costs at the
end our first example from an fta1
letters shows why user management and
personalized user accounts are so
important
in this case
an analyst work with a common user
account or shared user account
so it was not longer possible to track
who generate the data or make changes
to the system settings
therefore each user should work with
their own personalized user account it
should be an unique account and the
instrument must have functionalities to
prevent this account from being used by
other users
this includes complex passwords
locking the account after too many wrong
logins or even the automatic logout
after inactivity
especially with an essential laboratory
instrument
such like a balance or a ph meter which
is present
several times in the laboratory a
central administration of the users is
very helpful
so that the users do not have to manage
on each instrument
and optimal case this is a direct
integration of the instrument into the
copyright domain or active directory
without any additional software in
between
this is for example possible with the
cubist 2 via ldap protocol
and this makes the handling easiest for
user as they do not have to remember
passwords for different laboratory
systems they can log on with their
windows account password and it also
makes the administration simpler and
faster
another example from the same warning
letter is
that the users not only used a shared
account
this account has also administrative
right that allow changing the date and
time on the system or maybe also other
system settings
through which manipulations were
possible
therefore the system should have a role
management in addition to the user
management so that the users only have
the rights that they need for their
daily laboratory work and do not have
the possibility to change critical
system parameters as a normal laboratory
technician
role management should be also
customizable
so that the roles and
the linked rights can be adapted to your
company needs and
to the related sops
this example shows also another
important point
the importance of the correct time
with modern network devices and
instrument it should not longer be
necessary to change the time manually on
the system an automatic time
synchronization can ensure that the time
on the instrument always have
be correct
this is especially important for simple
embedded systems since the time he can
drift away after one or two months
yeah problems with the outer trail
like you can read in this warning
letters can often be found
here an audit trail was not activated
or it was possible to deactivate the
outer trail and therefore it was not
possible to detect changes in the system
such as changing the time or deleting
data
and this again lead to data integrity
violations
therefore you should always buy a
laboratory instrument that has an audit
trail and in the back
best case it should not be able to
switch off the outer trail and to
prevent the problem
however
it is also important that the audit
trail is regularly checked for
violations
and also to ensure that the instrument
is still in a validated state
and
therefore the auditor should be easy to
understand
you should have an option to export the
audit trail for review on a pc
because you don't want to do this
directly on the instrument
and yeah also a sort and filter function
could be very helpful
to find specific entries
inside the audit trail
yes i think the next violation is clear
to understand the records were not
signed and therefore
not assignable to an individual
and this can be prevented very easily if
the system is forcing electronic
signatures before a record is created
together with very strict passwords and
personalized user account you have then
a very proof and clear assignment to
each record
this warning letter contains two
important statements related to data
handling often stand-alone instrument
on one hand it was possible to delete
data like auto-trail and on the other
hand the data could not be restored
because no backup was created
with a reliable instrument in regulated
environment it should not be possible to
delete data on the instrument under
normal conditions
data that is not correct um for example
because something was weighed in
incorrectly should only be marked as
invalid together with reason but never
deleted
so that
everything remains traceable
even if the data cannot be deleted by
user data loose can always happen due to
hardware defects and therefore an
instrument should have a backup
functionality and the backup should be
performed
in a regular way
with our keywords to balance
we have solved it very simply and safely
the backup is automatically transferred
to a server in the network at the
preset time interval and so no user
action is necessary for this
procedure
we also recommend that the file formats
are chosen for archiving
the data
are also still readable in 30 years and
therefore are not vendor-specific
an
accepted file format in the
pharmaceutical industry is a pdf format
additional security can be provided by
generating a checksum
of the pdf file the checksum can be used
later to verify that the pdf has not
been manipulated and is still the
original one
another problem especially with the
balance is the attention of the
measurement uncertainties
as we know every measured value is
subject to an uncertainty which can
affect our results or our experiment
especially very small sample weights are
subject to very large relative
uncertainties
and therefore you should not perform any
weighing below the minimum sample weight
but also the measurements above has
uncertainties which have to be known to
interpret the results correctly
a modern instrument can support you in
this by providing workflow support for
the determination of the working range
prevent weighing below the minimum
sample weight
and also display and document the
measurement uncertainty of each measured
value
and all these helps you to get very
trustable results for your experiment
so now our last fda warning letter and
as you can see from this it is also
always important that the system status
is monitored
to ensure compliant operation
in this case here no attention was paid
to the fact
if there were networked or power
interruption during operation which
could also lead to incorrect
data or results
laboratory instrument or system should
therefore indicate the system status and
one if necessary
with the qs2 balance for example we have
centralized this in a status center
that clearly shows the user the system
status of the balance and in the event
of problems it provides also support how
to resolve the problem
furthermore you can block the balance
when it's out of specification for
example
not level um that you only make
measurements inside the specification
i hope these examples have shown you how
different the violations can be and how
modern laboratory instruments such as
the qs2 balance can prevent these issues
the laboratory instrument itself can
only support through its functions the
organization itself must always ensure
the compliance operation
and it is therefore always important to
identify the gxp relearn processes data
and system
and
to do a risk assessment based on this
then you should create sops and train
your users on the sops and
on proper data handling
also regular orders should be performed
and the qualified conditions of the
system should be ensured all together
with an open quality culture can prevent
problems through data integrity
violations
beside data integrity itself which also
refers to paper-based data the second
focus on the presentation is on the
connectivity which makes processes and
data exchange more secure and more
efficient
i think all of you know that
digitalization makes our processes
faster and more efficient and at the end
the data more secure and reliable
therefore
there has been a lot of talk about the
digital lab 4.0 and technologies such as
internet of things big data cloud
computing or blockchain
i don't want to dive too deep into these
topics the most important is for this
all the instruments processes and data
are linked together
and we need laboratory instruments that
fits perfectly in this environment and
support us in our digitalization
strategy
but when we take a look
in the laboratories today we don't see
this high level of integration
i think most of the laboratories are
working still with
these printouts when it comes to
essential laboratory instruments like
laboratory balance or a ph meter
and here you have the problem
is this digitalization
when you have 100 signatures and
correction and how will you bring these
data
into your limbs or eln system at the end
when the instrument is maybe directly
connected to the limbs or eln
then we see mostly only two scenarios
one is you have a serial cable
and integrate the instrument where the
serial interface but here's the big
question is this a safe data transfer
via ethereal connection
and um
includes the
the serial transfer or the required
meter data or is it still for example
the the weighing value
yeah when you have maybe a deeper
integration then you have quite often
some kind of converter or middleware in
between
the instrument and the lab system
so that the instrument is only connected
to these windows specific software and
then the software is integrated into the
web system but the big question is here
why you have this kind of software
because the software only increase the
complexity of your setup
you have much more effort when it comes
to validation and id maintenance and at
the end
increase your cost because on one hand
of the more effort of the complexity and
validation and on the other hand you
have much more item maintenance cost for
the extra software
and so on
yeah to make it better then in the
slides before you need some kind of
digital and compliant documentation
workflow to work 100
paperless
and how can this look like um i would
like to show you on an example with the
sartorius cubist 2 balance where we have
implement
these kind of workflow directly on the
balance
first of all you need a feature that you
can review results before you
create a report
this can be done on the curious to
directly on the balance and when you see
some kind of error inside your results
and you want to redo the test
you don't have to print it out then use
your pen cross the value
and make some
handwritten comments
and signatures on it you can do this
directly
on the balance and flag the result as
invalid and write your comment directly
on the balance touch screen
so when you have review your results and
make your corrections then you can
directly sign it on the balance with
your electronic signature as creator
this is very useful for you because
you don't have to go to the pc it can be
directly signed on the balance screen
and then you can continue directly you
work without
switching between pc and the balance
and after you have signed it with your
electronic signature
you will create a full compliant record
with all the required metadata
and you have several possibilities now
with the cubist 2 balance to generate
these report and to transfer it to
different
systems
and yeah what are the possibilities here
with cubist ii we offer
yeah future proof options for
integrating the balance into different
system
we know that not every company already
had the possibility to integrate
equipment directly into a laboratory
software or it is even a limbs or
elm still not in place
on the other hand many companies are
planning to implement the balance in the
next few years and do not want to buy a
new balance right away when the system
is alive
therefore cubies 2 grows with your
digitalization requirements
so today you can use the digital
documentation workflow as i shown before
in the slide
but still work with a normal lab printer
so you still have a paper-based solution
but instead of handwritten signatures or
crossing out invalid entries you can do
everything electronically directly on
the balance
when the balance is on the network the
paper-based entries can also be turned
into pdf files
that are sent to a file share or a
document management system
and this is the first step to going
completely paperless but still compliant
yeah and when you later want to
integrate the cubist to balance directly
into your limbs or eln system
also here the cubist ii has different
possibilities
for a full compliant integration over
network without the need for any
additional hardware or converter or
software in between
so
i think the simplest way what is also
supported by most of the lims or elm
systems is
that you create an ascii file directly
on the balance for example a csv file
and transfer it to a file share where
the file is read in or passed in
by the software system
and um
this is very easy to implement i think
on both sides it's a standard feature of
the cubist but also um
on the lymph side
and the other case is what we support
with the balance
to make a direct connection to a
database server for example a microsoft
sql server to store data or read data
from this database server
and
also we support
rest web services
this is also an interface
what can be used by many software system
to
communicate
with the balance
to read data from the balance and
to send data to the balance
and the rest web service interface
allows also
a deep
bi-directional and seamless integration
of the balance
over the network
into some software system and i will now
show you with two example how it works
yeah as i said i would
like to show you now how the full
integration of the balance can look like
into different laboratory systems
and
we create these both examples
together with partners and um it shows
you not only how a paperless
and deep integrated solution
works um it shows you also how this
solution
can help you to increase the efficiency
in the laboratory and be compliant with
the common regulations
yeah first i would like to show you the
integration of the cubist ii balance
into omnis metroom's titration platform
to make the process more efficient and
safer
here we follow a plug-and-play
integration which is based on web
services and complies with all i.t
security standards such as
the
encrypted communication
and it makes the integration very simple
the solution is of course fully 21 part
11 and unx 11 compliant the utility
management and audit trail storage is
done centrally in omnis and yeah how
does it work in detail
yeah the biggest advantage is that all
weighing related steps can be performed
directly on the touch screen of the qs2
balance without having a computer next
to it
this saves space and you can concentrate
fully on the sample
the weighing
process can also be
initiated directly
at the balance
um as you can see on the left screen you
can select the rect position for the
sample directly on the screen
and then you will guide it step by step
through the weighing process
doing weighing all relevant informations
for example the sample name or the
method is display on the screen
and at the end the weights are saved
directly in omnis with all required
metadata
another advantage of the integration is
that the user can use different on the
system with only one balance
it is not only a one-to-one relationship
as it's known for example with simple
errors two three two connections
where um yeah each balance is linked to
only one system exclusive
i think this solution what we have done
together with metro
shows how different vendors can linked
system
to gather over it standards very easily
and provide their customers
a very efficient and safe solution
yeah
another good example for a deep
integration wire standard interface is a
seamless integration in a limbs
here together with stalin's from abbott
informatics
the goal of this integration was to
design a limbs balance integration based
on web services
that is on one hand easy to set up
but also fully compliant with the higher
standards of data integrity at i.t
security
the modern web servers based technology
allows us to design something that is
much better than the traditional way of
setting up these balance limbs
connection via error 232 or file
transfer
the entire preparation such as the
assignment of the sample id
to the sample or the selection of the
method is done inside the starlands
the entire weighing process can now be
executed directly on the balance without
the need for a computer beside the
balance
perfectly the samples then have an
electronic readable sample id for
yeah for example a barcode or an rfib
code so that this id can be read
directly with a scanner
that is connected to the balance
of course it would also be possible to
enter a sample id via the balance
touchscreen but
yeah this brings the risk of errors
after that the balance checks if all
conditions or specifications are
fulfilled
so that the balance is calibrated the
user who is locked in is allowed to work
with this kind of sample or method
and also if it's the right balance type
for the sample
the user is then guided step by step
through the weighing process and all
relevant sample informations are
displayed on the sample screen
and at the end the results are
transferred back to the limbs together
with all the required metadata
such
paperless and compliant integration not
only prevents data integrity violation
it also increases efficiency in the
laboratory with the direct integration
and you save additional operational
costs that would be generated by a
middleware software or converter between
the limbs and the balance
i think here we show together with
abbott informatics how an integration
from an instrument into a limbs in the
future should look
like
yeah that brings us to the end of the
final section
i hope i could show you with these
examples the possibility of integrating
the cubist 2 balance into different
software systems and how this can
achieve maximum compliance lower it
costs and higher efficiency in the
laboratory
please feel free to contact us or visit
our website for more information about
the cubist 2 balance or the integration
solutions with our partners
yeah at the end i can only say thank you
all very much for taking the time to
listen to this presentation
i hope this has given you an insight
into the problems of data integrity and
connectivity of
laboratory instruments and how these can
be solved with the modern instrument
like the cubist 2 balance
i'm very happy to receive your questions
and
yeah thank you and have a nice day
thank you sebastian for your informative
presentation
joining me now is peter hickey as we
begin the live q a session
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
all right let's get started our first
question here asks what technical
controls are on the cubist 2 balance to
ensure full 21 cfr part 11 compliance
all right um okay so on the 21 cfr
compliance technical control
um on the cubist balance what we have
here is
we have the user management we have the
audit trail and the alibi memory
we also have got the safe data transfer
process plus the backup availability
and
just
finishing with time synchronization
and also we have the facility to have
e-signatures
now these technical controls for
the cubist ii balance
are all on the balance there isn't the
requirement to have external software
to do this um because i know there are
systems um other products that you know
they will cover all of that but they
will require the use of
an external software pack so just to
highlight
these technical controls that i've
listed
and they're all
very much part of the whole 21 cfr
compliance
requirements
to give you the alcoa principle data
but they're all on the balance yeah and
it's it's quite a powerful system
and it's been very very well received
um i'm hoping i've covered everything on
that if there's any any qualification
needed on it please
please feel free to put another question
in the box
great thank you peter this next question
asks how can i make sure that the pdf
documents have not been manipulated
okay
right so uh that's an interesting one uh
yes so anytime you send dasa
to
a
a next you know a source you you're
sending data to another location
it's always going to generate a checksum
file or an md5 file which is basically a
file generated algorithm
um so that will always follow the data
so if you're sending data to the server
it'll go with the md5 the lim system
will have the uh file generated
algorithm in place so basically you
always have that security that the data
is over the companies that it checks on
so this that means you can check that
the data is as per the original data
that went out uh from the balance so
it's a checksum system
great thank you
all right this next question asks how
many users can be created on the balance
ah okay so
um
there to be honest with you there isn't
actually a limit of the number of users
to be created on the balance now
obviously
um
the facility to have it
corporate directory active directory
control on the balance does help with
this
but i know that we have done tests in
our r d
and that's where we have had up to 10
000 users on a balance
so
there is no restriction really on the
numbers of um of users on the balance
and as i say because it's a it's you
know it helps because it's all centrally
controlled
um with regard to that so no limit
great all right
next question here what happens if the
connection to the file share does not
work will the data be deleted
okay
so if the connection
to the file share is interrupted for
whatever reason
it will generate an error message
yeah
and you will be given options um
you can retry
you can redirect or you can cancel
but the data will not be deleted
and the data will be saved into the ring
memory of the balance until this
connection is actually remade
so that's from that perspective it's
quite secure
great
all right this next question has a few
parts to it
it starts out what is the current
expected durability of the touch screen
panel especially if multiple samples are
weighed or screen touch activity chances
of decrease in sensitivity or ghost
touches are common in touch screen
okay well we're yes i mean i know that
the touchscreen technology has moved on
very very dramatically especially in the
last perfect two years
um i know that when we developed the
cubist ii
um
two years ago you know we basically went
with the high options where we're using
this uh tft display um it is very much
uh
designed for
you know
lots of a piece of tube it needs to be
able to withstand that type of uh
extensive activity on the balance on the
balance so we haven't seen that we
haven't seen any issues with the
touchscreen um as i say it's been
developed with that in mind
great thank you looks like we have time
for a few more questions here this next
one what are the weight ranges of the
balance models
okay the weight ranges so where okay so
in the cubist two range
we go from sort of seven digit high
uh resolution balances so that you know
micro balances and ultra micro balances
so they would start a capacity of 2.1
grams and really down to seven digits
and then you go right up to the circle's
large scale
high capacity precision balances which
would be our cutoff currently would be
70 kilos
our balances tend to end up in both the
lab but also the production
and i think it's always a very good
thing when the users are using the same
um
the same sort of
functionality and the same
interfacing as they're using in the lab
are in the production environment or in
the scale of pilot scale lab that type
of thing so as i say 2.1 grams at the
high resolution end
micro balance up to 70 kilos on the high
capacity precision balance
wonderful thank you
this next question asks how much results
can be saved will i have memory full
okay
so
so basically the results that are saved
are the results um are you know we we
use a process called alibi data so every
time we generate data and there is a
copy of the data on the balance which is
the alibi data but you know we don't
store
other results on the balance we
basically give you a preview of your
results and then you decide what to do
with it now with regard to the alibi
data filling up yes there is it is it is
storage on on a on a system it will
eventually fill up but you know it is
quite a high memory of um
available ring memory on the balance for
alibi data you're typically talking
depending on the use of the balance you
know it could be four to six years
before it actually overrides all data
but you always have the facility to back
up
and to import your alibi data and you
know
you're always will be pre-warned that
it's about to overwrite old data but
there's there will not be any data
thank you looks like we have time for
one more question here is there a
specific software to make user login to
the balances
um okay so we're using
software if you like so that's the
balance software this is where the uh
the user and um application management
is is set up
and so that's basically on the ballot
and then depending on how you want to
connect to the balance
um
you know a lot of people are using their
own corporate active directory ldap
facility so this in conjunction with the
uh the balance functionality to manage
profiles and to set roles for various
profiles so essentially all of that
functionality is unbalanced
great and we actually have time for one
more question in here so we'll ask this
one
once a balance has been validated can
other balances be configured the same
remotely if on a shared network
um sorry once the balance is invalidated
can all the balances be configured the
same remotely when it's shared well it
is possible to
match up settings um with regard to two
balances so it is possible actually to
clone um balances with regard to the
setup i i'm assuming that's what's meant
by this question here um
but it's you know so so from that
perspective yes you can do that
great thank you well thank you again
sebastian and peter for your time today
and your important research we would
also like to thank lab roots and our
sponsor sartorius for underwriting
today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we do not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time take care everyone
goodbye
you